hello everyone this is amir from audio
science review
just finished doing a review of the new
topping
d30 pro dac and post it to the forum but
i thought i also do a
quick video on it this is what the box
looks like
it's typical of topping very well built
quite solid
uh beautiful display of a soft spot for
these
orange leds um pretty functional you
know
usual rotary uh rotary uh encoder
comes with a remote standard remote from
a lot of chinese companies
um the back what's unusual about this
little uh
deck is that it has balanced output
usually in this size
in configuration we get just rca
outs we have the usual coax and
and optical and usb inputs of course
another nice thing is the mains input
power supply is built in
so you don't have a wall wart to sit
outside and
take up space and uh with that out of
the way
uh let's take a look at the measurements
on this let me switch the browser
see the giveaway rating i've already
given to the topping but let's go
through the
performance usually
we all zoom in and look at this area
which is the synapt score
sinat is the sum of the noise and
distortion
and then you take a ratio of that
relative to the signal itself
in this case the signal itself is a one
kilohertz tone as you see over here
i've set it to zero on top uh in this
fft display
and this 119 is saying if you add the
noise and distortion together
everything is 119 120 db
below reference um best case threshold
of
hearing is about 115 db so this is 5 db
better than
absolute transparency there's no way no
how
you could hear the noise or the
distortion from the stack
so it's absolutely uh transparent and
then furthermore distortion which can be
more objectionable than noise is down at
minus 130 db
135 db you can see minus 130 here and
the first spike the second harmonic is
way down here
it's just incredible how good these dacs
have gotten
in the last year year and a half this
used to be
unattainable even state of the art decks
just two years ago
but here we are the balance output puts
out a little bit over four volts
like to always see at least four volts
in there and uh
they've eked out a little bit more than
four volts out of it
um with this uh you know my massive
ranking of 100
i don't know 250 300 decks that i've
tested
it ranks way up there so if we zoom in
we see this number 11 although
difference between number 11 and number
one is just two db's
so this is really not significant it's
just showing you
sort of this rivalry that's going on
between companies to try to beat each
other at this game
but to be this good with what is
basically a low-cost stack
is just incredible uh some of you don't
have balanced output
uh shame on you low-balance input i
should say on your
rest of electronics i'd love to see a
system that's into and balance
because that lowers the chance of
getting ground loops which are quite
nasty and once you have them
they're tough to get rid of and
but if you don't have it you just have
rca output to your powered speaker or
downstream preamp or headphone deck
headphone amplifier performance is
almost as good you just lose a db or so
and of course the output is not two
volts
as you would expect for unbalanced
connection
uh dynamic range is uh 128 db
um which means this is a difference
between basically a very low
amplitude signal and a max and
telling you that you get more than 21
bits of dynamic range now you might
think oh i've got 24-bit uh
music this must not be very good turns
out it's just physically impossible to
do much better than this
at room temperature even a single
resistor could produce more noise than
this
so 20 wide one bits is just incredibly
good
um cd of course is 16 bits so
this you have five extra bits of bedroom
over here
so quite excellent um another test we
run is that this intermodulation
distortion this is a
60 hertz and seven kilohertz two tones
and they have a four to one ratio
and then we measure the distortion
that's generated between these two tones
and we sweep these from very low level
to all the way to the maximum so at very
low level
noise dominates that's where these
curves always sort of point down
scale down at some point distortion
picks up as you can see this in this
little
phone dongle uh and then distortion
dominance when the curve flattens and
goes up
um with the d30 pro it basically is all
noise limited distortion it's just not
an issue
and it just sinks lower and lower this
is a
topping dx3 pro the
little brother to this one that's been
out for a year and a half or so
and you can see the performance gap is
just incredible
relative to that these are very hard
improvements to get when you already
have a good deck
another test i run is called linearity
it's a single tone
and we filter out everything outside of
the tone so we're just looking for the
accuracy of that voltage we ask the dac
to produce x
in digital domain we expect it to
produce the same in analog domain and
we keep increasing it you know one bit
at a time and the two have to track
if they track perfectly you get a
horizontal line and that's basically
what we have in here
the little wiggleness you're going to
get because a little bit of noise gets
in the way
this is exceptional something you don't
see in the static test is that when i
run this on some other dax
there's enough noise in there that the
analyzer struggles to capture these
samples here they're so accurate and so
noise free
that it just was a flat lining around
very quickly
which is exceptional the next test i run
uh is for everybody else not me i'm not
too worried about how the dac filters
work they tend to not be
having much audible effect except for
when you use this one
blue one which is basically no filtering
you want to avoid that
but all the other filters are plotted i
always like the ones that attenuate the
most
and here we can see this one in purple
or whatever color it is
on a monitor it has the most attenuation
which is what you
want and now
most of these filters are not
mathematically correct
and this one's one of them unfortunately
is quite common
this is a 44.1 kilohertz sampling rate
which is same as cd and most of the
streaming content
so you want half of that to have all the
signal chopped off
and the half of that would be where this
cursor line and red is
we don't have that it takes its time and
goes down at 24 kilohertz this is
very common uh it's a function of what
the chip company provides
these uh so there's not much topping can
do about it
and in in reality the effect is very
minor because
your music is not going to have a lot of
spectrum between 20 and 22 kilohertz for
it to
mirror out so would be nice if it was
sharper but
again this is very typical and once
there i want to see very good
attenuation which the stack has
some dax or some avr's uh the dax in
them
you know only go to minus 70 or so uh
whereas this you can see it's almost
down to one that's minus 110 which is
great
um this test was an exception um
this is a 99 board that i tested a long
time ago that i use as
reference in blue and surprisingly a
dactyls good all of a sudden shows far
higher
higher noise and distortion sum together
t ht plus n
uh thd stands for harmonic distortion
and n stands for noise
so we can see there's a lot worse but
this test is actually kind of tricky
in that to capture all the harmonic
distortion
um we need to have wide bandwidth for
our test uh the
test signal goes up to 20 kilohertz so
his second harmonic
uh distortion would be at 40 kilos
already third harmonic would be 60 and
so forth so from beginning
i've set this test to have 90 kills
bandwidth
so you can capture up to a fourth
harmonic of 200 kilos
the problem doing that is that it then
captures a lot of things that are in
ultrasonic domain they're not very
audible
but show up in here and and you know i
say where's the eye
and so we have to see if it should worry
the ear or at the same time so
i then run a spectrum test so we can see
what's above our
you know 20 kilohertz bandwidth that we
use for the previous test
and we see that the noise is very low
actually and so it's distortion
distortion is down to -135 so quite a
bit lower than what we saw in the
previous steps
but right around 45 kilos all of a
sudden takes off
the reason for that is the special
signal processing technique that's used
to reduce
noise in the audible band by pushing it
out into the ultrasonic band
this is called noise shaping uh it's a
difficult concept for you to understand
perhaps just take my word for it that
you can sort of
take things from one uh pocket if you
put it in the other pocket that doesn't
matter as much
so um and this kind of noise is so low
at minus 110 db
and it's not going to make it to your
twitter or your headphones
and you're certainly not going to hear
it so it's just
a measurement artifact of having to uh
increase bandwidth to capture this so it
captures stuff that is not an issue
uh now if this problem was way down here
then we'd worry about it but
but where it is it's just not a concern
um the next test is what i call jitter
test it's a special
signal called the j-test and
i won't go into it now but essentially
think of it as
a pure 12 kilohertz tone and nothing
else
so the most perfect result would be this
one spike in the middle
and then these two shoulders would would
not even be seen
um in this case we see the shoulders way
down here so low that it actually
hiding on the audio science review logo
here so that's exceptionally low noise
floor we see tiny little ticks in here
down to minus 150
db or so and some of their power supply
relay that usually go up a little bit
more but again
we're talking minus 140 db remember our
set threshold of hearing is -115
so these are just absolutely not a
audible concern
now typically when i run this test
especially on on dax that use akm chip
that doesn't have resampler the coax and
toslink inputs tend to do a lot worse
than usb
uh hopefully most of you are using usb
but sometimes you have a tv with
touchlink output and
or a game console what have you so
people care about that also
and here we see that performance
identical on all three so either has
extremely good clock generation
and extraction out of tossing and coax
or is resampling internally
and throwing out all the input jitter i
don't know which but either way
it's actually on result and it's just
very very nice to see uh
such good performance finally it is a
multi-tone test
a lot of people like this visually
kind of an attractive test in that we
take 32 tones
you can see their levels here and
run them through the dac digitally and
ask it to produce an analog output
and whatever shows up in between these
bands is intermodulation distortion
and an ideal dac would have infinite
troughs over here
and nothing in between them in practice
we get noise
from both the attack and my analyzer and
uh
we see that the uh the worst case noise
is 112
and distortion noise is minus 120
which is 20 bits already and then it
sinks
way down to almost 135 db
so that's exceptional performance for
any deck
let alone a bargain deck so net net
is another support product from topping
um
some people say i'm in their pocket for
some reason
i'll tell you there's no mystery in here
this is the uh
manual that came with with this stack
and
uh you know you you look at it hopefully
uh that's the case with this one yeah
look at the uh all the measurements in
there this looks surprisingly like mine
what does that mean the company has a
proper audio analyzer like my audio
precision there during the design and
they measure the performance and they
find problems and they fix them
other companies wait to for me to find
them the first time
because they haven't done their job
oftentimes the fixes are simple you may
have to just adjust the component
move something around isolate something
to get rid of noise
none of that costs money but you need to
have the tools to tell you that
you can't use your ears when the
distortions are so
low and noise levels are so low they're
way beyond threshold of hearing
so you want to you know do that in
design phase and when you do that then
you're going you have a great product
and my job's easy i'm just basically
confirming independently what they've
done
and performance is this good so there's
uh
you know no nothing else is needed over
here as far as trickery or what have you
just built a great product and you get
my praise for it
so that's it thanks for watching this is
my
first video on youtube thank you bye